the shape of a person's face is the
consequence of genetic roulette but
while core traits like hair and eye
color are largely determined by a few
genes little is known about the nuances
of a person's face a major yet
unresolved question in decoding the
human genome is what determines
subtleties like the shape of a person's
lips or the prominence of their
cheekbones what about one's risk for
birth defects axial vessel and
colleagues are now coming face-to-face
with the answers enhancers or pieces of
DNA that facilitate gene expression they
are the tuners of the genome modulating
how a gene is realized surprisingly
these tiny tuners actually have a
powerful influence in orchestrating the
activity of our DNA the difficulty in
studying enhancers lies and spotting
them while it's easy to find protein
coding genes in the genome it's much
more difficult to find enhancers that's
because they don't need to be right next
to the genes that they enhance in order
to find them the researchers first
collected face tissue for mouse embryos
and used a method called chip sequencing
this is where proteins that bind to
enhancers are cross-linked with DNA
which is then shredded into short
segments they attached antibodies to the
proteins in order to isolate the DNA
then through parallel sequencing they
looked for peaks in the genome short
segments pulled out over and over again
the peaks are the most likely locations
for enhancers giving them a region to
focus on with this method the
researchers identified several thousand
small regions in the genome that are
likely to be enhancers that are active
as the face develops this 3d figure
shows what areas one such enhancer
effects in this case the enhancer drives
expression in the red regions this
includes the front area of the nose in
the developing palate to gather more
precise data about the function of this
enhancer the researchers removed it from
the mouse genome by using 3d imaging
they confirmed that manipulating
different enhancers did indeed change
the shape of the face and skull of
course mouse and human faces look much
different from one another however many
of the enhancers identified in the mouse
genome have similar sequences at coors
bonding positions in the human genome
therefore it seems likely that enhancers
play a comparable role in human
craniofacial development disparities and
enhancers probably play a role in making
our faces different from each other such
knowledge will be useful in studying the
role of enhancers and other treats and
diseases on a genome-wide scale
researchers are still a long way from
being able to reconstruct a person's
face just from the sequence information
in their DNA however the powerful
influence of these tiny tuners is
flinging open the doors for further
research enhancing the future of genetic
exploration
you